uh you've said that you won't nominate
ministers to you know form a new
executive until your concerns are
resolved about the northern ireland
protocol what exactly do you want to see
happen
well i think it's time now after months
and months of interminable negotiations
between the uk government and the eu
for decisive action we've been patient
we've waited and waited and waited but
there's been no outcome from those
negotiations and we heard last night
from liz trust who's leading the uk
negotiating team
that they've rejected the eu's proposals
from last october so there's it appears
there is no basis upon which an
agreement is likely in the short to
medium term and in the absence of such
an agreement we believe that the uk
government should act to protect the uk
internal market and northern ireland's
place within it
so let's be clear about what that would
mean you effectively say the uk
government should unilaterally act
without agreement from the eu to scrap
parts of the deal that they signed i
mean that would be breaking
international law wouldn't it and also
potentially risking a trade war with the
eu
well of course the protocol itself makes
provision for unilateral action where
the protocol is causing harm economic
harm political harm societal harm and it
is evident and the uk government in its
command paper last july stated that the
protocol is harming northern ireland
it's harming our economy it is
undermining political stability here so
i think in those circumstances and in
order to safeguard the belfast or good
friday agreement and the political
institutions the uk government is well
within its rights to act in these
circumstances
do you really trust the uk government
to act as you say boris johnson's been
promising action for months
well i think that uh in terms of uh the
government um i'm not going to take it
uh just on the basis of words and we did
have words yesterday in the queen's
speech but we need to see action and
that's what i will judge the government
by at what action they're prepared to
take to deal with the real difficulties
that this protocol is causing for
northern ireland
so on friday because i want to talk a
little bit about what you're prepared to
do on friday the newly elected northern
ireland assembly will meet to elect a
new speaker now really the assembly
can't function until that happens and it
needs cross-party support to do so will
the dep support that
election well we're waiting to hear from
the government we want to see what the
government has to say
we will meet before friday and decide uh
our course of action in relation to uh
the proceedings in the assembly on
friday so i'm not in a position to say
right now but we are clear we need
government action
so it seems pretty clear that you're
keeping on the table the fact that you
might not even support a speaker at
being nominated for the assembly i mean
some would say shin fame would say that
you're effectively holding northern
ireland to ransom
well of course sinn fein for three years
prevented not only the election of a
speaker but the appointment of an
executive for three whole years 1044
days sinn fein didn't turn up to the
executive and the assembly to do their
job so i won't take any lectures from
sinn fein on that point
but at the same time you know what about
the people in northern ireland who voted
for you many people voted for you to get
go to the northern ireland assembly to
help with lots of issues including the
cost of living crisis and they might say
hang on don't we deserve to have an
assembly that's functioning
well of course they do and i want a
functioning assembly but the assembly
can't function in the absence of a
cross-community consensus and when i
stood before the people with my party in
the election we made clear we wouldn't
be forming an executive until the
protocol issues are dealt with so i have
a mandate to do what i'm doing and i
intend to hold by that mandate
you say you have a mandate but at the
same time the majority of people voted
for parties who accept or people who
accept the northern ireland protocol 54
of the 90 newly elected mlas accept the
protocol so do you really have a mandate
to do this
yes i do because the assembly operates
not on majority rule as because when
unionists were in the majority of course
nationals would not accept majority rule
and therefore at the heart of the
belfast agreement is the principle of
power sharing by consensus and there
isn't a consensus at the moment on the
protocol and we need to have that
consensus that is the basis upon which a
government can be formed that is right
that is the core central principle of
the belfast or good friday agreement it
is power sharing by consensus and not a
single unionist uh mla elected to the
assembly last week supports the protocol
and if this situation were reversed does
anyone seriously believe uh that
nationalism would be ignored that the
nationalist parties would simply be
dismissed of course they wouldn't their
concerns would be addressed and it's
important that unionist concerns are
addressed if we're to have that power
sharing on a cross-community consensus
basis
okay i want to talk a bit more about the
protocol and the brexit deal uh because
of it was was obviously negotiated by
boris johnson uh he told us it was a
brilliant deal
at the time uh and i just want to play a
quick clip of what boris johnson told me
this is december 2019 so
around the time of when it was agreed
let's just listen
there's no question of there being
checks
on goods going uh nigb or gbni because
they're part of if you look at what the
deal is
we're part of the same customs territory
so he said there will be absolutely no
checks there'll be no question of there
being checks on goods going nigb or gbni
do you think boris johnson didn't
understand what he was signing or do you
think he just wasn't telling the truth
well look i don't know the answer to
that question sophie i think only the
prime minister can answer that but i can
tell you this that in the house of
commons when these matters were debated
the dup pointed out very clearly to the
prime minister what the protocol would
mean in practice it would mean customs
checks on goods moving between great
britain and northern it would mean
additional costs delays more paperwork
for businesses in northern it would uh
drive up the cost
for consumers in northern ireland of
goods that have come from great britain
and that has been the case today the
cost of living crisis in northern is
being exacerbated by the fact that it
costs a lot more now to bring goods from
great britain to northern the road
haulage association estimate that the
additional cost of transporting goods as
a result of the protocol is 27 in the
first year of its operation that means
food prices are dearer here in northern
than they are in great britain it means
that consumers households hard-pressed
households at the moment who are facing
higher energy bills are also facing
higher food bills because of the
protocol and that's not acceptable and
that's why we're saying the prime
minister must act if the prime minister
believes that the right that the right
outcome is that there should not be any
checks on goods moving from great
britain to northern then that's the
outcome we all want to see
you also had an exchange with theresa
may uh in the house of commons yesterday
i just want to play her response to you
because she obviously thinks that you
should have signed up to the deal she
had on the table let's listen
i put a deal before this house which
which actually met the requirements of
the good friday agreement
and actually enabled us not to have a
border down the rsc or to have a border
between northern ireland and the public
violence sadly the dup and others across
this house chose to reject that but it
was just such an opportunity for what he
wanted
she's right isn't she there had been a
lot lighter checks under her deal do you
regret not backing it
not at all sophie because of course um
theresa may's deal with the backstop
would have put in place a temporary
transitional arrangement whereby for uh
two years after uh the uk had left the
european union all of the united kingdom
would remain in the eu customs union and
the eu single market
after two years great britain alone
would have the right to leave the
customs union on the single market
leaving northern ireland permanently
stuck in both the eu single market and
customs union now
bad and all the protocol is that's a far
worse outcome for northern that would
leave a permanent uh
barrier a border between northern
ireland and great britain we would have
been outside the uk customs union
currently were inside it we would have
been outside the uk internal market
currently we're inside it but the
protocol creates barriers to trade
within the uk internal markets so that's
why we need those barriers to remove
that so-called rec border and to put in
place arrangements that protect both the
uk internal market and the eu single
market and we believe there are
pragmatic solutions there that will that
will satisfy everyone's needs but the
protocol certainly doesn't do that okay
if just finally if the government does
take action if you are satisfied on the
protocol and i appreciate that feels
like a long way away it's a big if at
the minute
will you commit to facilitating a sinn
fein first minister by nominating a
deputy
well it's not a matter of facilitating
sinn fein we accept the outcome of the
election it is a matter of facilitating
the formation of an executive and yes we
will nominate our ministers to an
executive because we want to get on with
the business of government and providing
good stable government for northern
ireland but sadly the uh
the long shadow of the protocol is uh
leaving its mark on uh politics in
northern at the moment it has created
instability it has undermined the very
delicately balanced arrangements that
were put in place through the belfast
and successor agreements that's why we
need this matter dealt with i want to
see stable institutions i want to see
northern ireland prospering that means
uh the protocol has to be dealt with and
decisive action is required
okay uh thank you very much indeed
jeffrey donaldson there of dp
thank you
well in a moment we'll get reaction
directly from the government but let's
first see what our senior island
correspondent david blevins makes of
that uh david what jumped out to you
from that interview
well i think it is crystal clear sophie
that the dup has no intention of
participating in the election of a first
and deputy first minister at this point
and therefore northern ireland isn't
going to have a government for a while
but there are two things to watch
carefully i think in the coming days
on friday as you pointed out the first
plenary session of the new northern
ireland assembly is due to take place
for the election of a speaker will the
dup participate in that election if not
it will be a signal
that they think this is going to
linger this crisis in fact that will
deepen the crisis because there won't
even be a government in a sort of shadow
form in northern ireland the other thing
to watch for is what sir jeffrey himself
does he has eight days from the northern
ireland election to resign his own seat
as the member of parliament for lagund
valley and occupy the state he's just
been elected to in the northern ireland
assembly again if he chooses not to do
that at this point it will be an
indication that the dup don't expect any
speedy movement from the government on
the protocol